comme ce petit bout de foule sont 2650
baskets aux pieds et casquette vissée
sur la tête de la maternelle au collège
tous les enfants de schoelcher
toucheront aujourd'hui à plusieurs
activités sportives différentes premier
exercice la bonne prise
j'aime bien voir la base si la raquette
je joue et j'appelle à charge après
janvier comme ceci aussi ok la
perspective des jo-2000 24 à paris
inciter le ministère de la jeunesse et
des sports à pérenniser cette fête du
sport au niveau national depuis l'an
dernier
le rendez vous est donc pris à chaque
rentrée et les enfants sont à fond les
enfants est-ce que vous appréciez votre
journée vous aimez en fait danser les
enfants
c'est un rendez vous qu'ils attendent
n'oubliez pas qu'ils arrivent en karl
donc le voyage commence déjà et il
il rencontre des copains qui n'ont
jamais vue ils sont sur des écoles
qu'ils n'ont jamais vus sur des sites
qu'ils n'ont jamais vu donc c'est
vraiment presse du koh lanta c'est une
aventure
selon l'inspecteur de la zone - d'un
enfant sur deux pratique est un sport en
dehors de l'école pourtant l'envié là
les infrastructures aussi ce matin ils
étaient tous propres pour pouvoir faire
le sport il était impatient et très
enthousiaste c'est vraiment l'âge où il
faut commencer à leur montrer toutes les
possibilités
oui c'est vraiment l'âge parce que à ce
à cet âge là ils sont vraiment ouvert à
tous pas et après ils pourront préciser
le sport day dans lequel ils se sentent
le plus à l'aise
enseignants animateurs 300 adultes ont
été mobilisés pour encadrer l'événement
le rectorat lance d'ailleurs un appel
aux parents pour venir nombreux la
prochaine fois